THESE COMMENTS ARE SO INSANE,
INAPPROPRIATE, OVER-THE-TOP COME
OUT OF LINE, WE WILL CALL OUT
THE MOB’S DESPICABLE COVERAGE.
FIRST AND I, LIKE EVERY NIGHT,
WE WANT TO START WITH FACTS
THAT WILL HELP YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY STAY SAFE AND SECURE
WITHOUT THE FEAR, HYSTERIA, AND
PANIC THAT OTHERS ARE PEDDLING.
CLEARLY, THE U.S. RESPONSE TO
THIS PANDEMIC IS UNLIKE ANYTHING
WE HAVE EVER WITNESSED OR EVER
SEEN.
TODAY, THE PRESIDENT INVOKED
WHAT IS KNOWN AS THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT.
THIS IS A MOVE THAT WILL
MASSIVELY RAMP UP THE PRODUCTION
AND THE DISTRIBUTION OF VERY
IMPORTANT MEDICAL SUPPLIES.
VENTILATORS, RESPIRATORS.
THIS WILL INCLUDE 500 MILLION
NEW AND 95 MASKS.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO DISPATCHED
EARLIER TODAY TWO NAVY HOSPITAL
SHIPS.
ONE TO THE EAST COAST, ONE TO
THE WEST COAST.
THE PENTAGON IS NOW PREPARING
MOBILE MEDICAL UNITS TO BE
DEPLOYED ALL OVER THE COUNTRY AS
THEY ARE NEEDED, IF THEY ARE
NEEDED.
MEANWHILE, AMERICA’S BRILLIANT
MEDICAL RESEARCHERS, SCIENTISTS,
DOCTORS, HEALTH CARE WORKERS,
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING AROUND
THE CLOCK AS USUAL.
NOT JUST ON A VACCINE, BUT ALSO
TREATMENTS THAT WILL MITIGATE OR
EVEN PREVENT THE CONTRACTION OF
THE VIRUS, OR THE EFFECTS OF THE
VIRUS IF YOU DO GET IT.
HOURS AGO, THE PRESIDENT GAVE US
A LITTLE PREVIEW OF WHAT WE CAN
EXPECT TOMORROW.
THIS IS GETTING INTERESTING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TOMORROW WE ARE HAVING WHAT I
THINK WILL BE A VERY INTERESTING
NEWS CONFERENCE.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT THAT’S
ALL ABOUT.
SO WE’LL SEE.
THE FDA, THEY’VE BEEN WORKING
VERY, VERY HARD AND I APPRECIATE
WHAT THEY’RE DOING, AND I THINK
WE HAVE SOME VERY INTERESTING
THINGS THAT WILL BE BROUGHT UP
TOMORROW AT THE NEWS CONFERENCE.
IT WILL BE SET UP AROUND 11:00
OR SO.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING YOU
TOMORROW.
>> Sean: SOME PRETTY EXCITING
NEWS, MEDICAL 18 IS HERE
TONIGHT.
WE ARE GOING TO EXAMINE WHAT THE
POSSIBILITIES ARE HERE.
THERE ARE NOW MULTIPLE ANTIVIRAL
MEDICATIONS BEING STUDIED.
MANY BEING TESTED.
ONE WAS PREVIOUSLY USED AGAINST
EBOLA.
ONE ANTIMALARIAL MEDICATION
DEVELOPED DECADES AGO SHOWING A
LOT OF PROMISE.
IT HAS BEEN USED IN THE COURSE
OF THIS PARTICULAR CORONAVIRUS
OUTBREAK, AND OF COURSE WE DO
EXPECT IN THE SHORT TERM THAT
THE CONFIRMED CASES WILL
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE.
WE ARE GOING TO PREPARE YOU FOR
THAT.
BUT AGAIN, IF WE ALL FOLLOW THE
RULES LAID OUT BY THE
PRESIDENT’S TASK FORCE, THEY’RE
NOT THAT DIFFICULT, WERE GOING
TO BE HELPING EVERY AMERICAN,
ESPECIALLY THE MOST VULNERABLE.
THE ELDERLY, WITH UNDERLYING
MEDICAL CONDITIONS, COMPROMISED
IMMUNE SYSTEMS.
IN THE MEANTIME, WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THE COMING ANNOUNCEMENT FROM
THE PRESIDENT AND THE FDA
TOMORROW.
WITHOUT A DOUBT COME OVER THE
GREATEST COUNTRY ON EARTH.
GOT TO REMEMBER THAT.
WE WILL GET THROUGH THIS.
WE’VE BEEN THROUGH TOUGH TIMES
AND WE ALWAYS PREVAIL.
AS THE PRESIDENT WE DID TONIGHT,
STRONG, UNITED, WE WILL PREVAIL.
HE POSTED THIS MESSAGE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WANT TO THANK ALL AMERICANS
FOR PULLING TOGETHER, DOING WHAT
THEY HAVE TO DO, IT’S BEEN
INCREDIBLE, INSPIRATIONAL, ALL
OVER THE WORLD THEY ARE
WATCHING.
OF COURSE, YOU’VE HEARD IT A
THOUSAND TIMES.
WASH YOUR HANDS, GOOD HYGIENE,
ALL OF THAT.
BUT SOCIAL DISTANCING, KEEP
AWAY.
IT’S GOING TO HAVE NO PLACE TO
GO.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU.
AS PRESIDENT, I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE INCREDIBLE JOB
YOU’RE ALL DOING.
THE SPIRIT OF OUR COUNTRY LIKE
NEVER BEFORE, WE REALLY HAVE
PULLED TOGETHER AS A UNIT, WE’VE
PULLED TOGETHER AS A COUNTRY.
WE WILL PREVAIL TOGETHER.
WE LOVE THE USA.
>> Sean: THIS IS AN ALL HANDS
ON DECK MOMENT AND WERE SEEING
THE GREATNESS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ON DISPLAY EVERY DAY.
AT EVERY LEVEL.
ONCE WE BEAT BACK THE VIRUS,
CHINA MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THERE HOSTILE GOVERNMENT CARES
MORE ABOUT OPTICS THAN THE LIVES
OF NOT ONLY THEIR OWN CITIZENS,
BUT THE WORLD COMMUNITY.
THIS MASSIVE COVER-UP AND THE
CRITICAL EARLY STAGES OF THIS
DISEASE, FRANKLY UNFORGIVABLE.
IT IS AN INDISPUTABLE FACT THAT
CHINA LIED.
PEOPLE ALL OVER THE WORLD ARE
SUFFERING AND DYING AS A RESULT
OF THESE LIES.
AXIOS REALLY PUT TOGETHER WHAT
IS A COMPREHENSIVE TIMELINE
THAT YOU NEED TO SEE.
WE WILL START ON DECEMBER THE
TENTH, 2019.
LAST YEAR, THAT IS 1 OF 1 OF THE
FIRST KNOWN CORONAVIRUS PATIENTS
BECOMES ILL.
THEN ON THE 27TH, WUHAN HEALTH
OFFICIALS DETERMINED A NEW TYPE
OF CORONAVIRUS WAS SPREADING.
THREE DAYS LATER ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, TOP DIRECTOR AT
THE WUHAN CENTRAL HOSPITAL TRIED
TO WARN THE PUBLIC ABOUT THIS
DANGEROUS NEW DISEASE AND HOW IT
WAS SPREADING FROM PERSON TO
PERSON.
SHE WAS SUBSEQUENTLY REPRIMANDED
AND CENSORED.
THEN ON JANUARY 1ST, 8 OTHER
DOCTORS WHO POSTED INFORMATION
ABOUT THE DISEASE ONLINE WERE
CALLED IN FOR QUESTIONING, ALSO
CENSORED.
JANUARY 7TH, THE PRESIDENT OF
CHINA BECAME DIRECTLY INVOLVED
IN THE RESPONSE.
JANUARY 11TH, THE WUHAN HEALTH
COMMISSION INSISTED THERE WERE
NO NEW CASES, WHICH WE NOW KNOW
IS A BLATANT LIE.
JANUARY 14TH, WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION AT THIS LATE DATE
TO EATING CHINESE AUTHORITIES
HAVE FOUND
NO CLEAR EVIDENCE OF HUMAN TO
HUMAN TRANSMISSION OF THE VIRUS.
REALLY?
THREE DAYS LATER CHINA HOSTED
ITS ANNUAL LUNAR NEW YEAR
BANQUET.
GUESS WHERE?
IN THE CITY OF WUHAN, WHERE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE GOT
TOGETHER FOR A POTLUCK SUPPER.
IT WASN’T UNTIL JANUARY 20 THAT
CHINA ADMITTED THE DISEASE CAN S
THE FIRST PERSON WE KNOW HAD
CORONA IN AMERICA ARRIVED ON
JANUARY 21ST, 10 DAYS LATER, THE
PRESIDENT’S TRAVEL BAN, THE
SINGLE BEST DECISION MADE TO
DATE BY ANY COUNTRY.
HE GAVE US TIME, SAVED COUNTLESS
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS FROM
CONTRACTING THE VIRUS, AND
LIKELY MANY DEATHS.
BY THE WAY, AT THAT POINT IT WAS
TOO LATE.
COVID-19 HAD ALREADY SPREAD TO
SOUTH KOREA.
A DAY LATER, THE FIRST CASE
CONFIRMED HERE.
THAT’S THE 21ST.
I’M JUST TALKING ABOUT.
PROBABLY ALREADY MULTIPLE CASES
IN ITALY, WHICH WE NOW HAVE
DISCOVERED HAD DIRECT FLIGHTS
FROM WUHAN, THAT PROVINCE, AND A
LARGE CHINESE POPULATION WORKING
IN THEIR TEXTILE INDUSTRY.
FOR WEEKS, CHINA COULD HAVE
SOUNDED THE ALARM.
INSTEAD, THEY LIED, THEY TRIED
TO COVER IT UP, AND THEY HAD
MASSIVE PUBLIC CELEBRATIONS AT
THE EPICENTER OF THIS DISEASE.
NOW CHINA’S GOVERNMENT, THERE
SPREADING BASIS CONSPIRACY
THEORIES BLAMING THE U.S.
MILITARY FOR THE SPREAD OF THE
DISEASE.
THERE ARE EVEN PROLIFERATING AND
INSANE TALKING POINT USING THE
WORD CHINA OR WUHAN VIRUS TO
DESCRIBE THE WUHAN VIRUS IS
RACIST.
AND OF COURSE MANY SOCIAL
JUSTICE WARRIORS IN THE MEDIA
MOB, NOT PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
THAT MUCH ABOUT HEALTH.
NO, THEY WANT POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS, EVEN AT A TIME LIKE
THIS.
UNWITTINGLY ECHOING WHAT IS A
CHINESE PROPAGANDA TALKING
POINT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> CHINA AND OTHERS HAVE
CRITICIZED YOU FOR USING THE
PHRASE "CHINESE VIRUS."
HOW DO YOU GO ABOUT THAT?
ARE YOU GOING TO CONTINUE TO USE
THAT PHRASE?
IT CREATES A STICK MAN.
>> WHY DO YOU KEEP
CALLING THIS THE CHINESE VIRUS?
THERE ARE REPORTS OF DOZENS OF
INCIDENTS OF BIAS AGAINST
CHINESE AMERICANS IN THIS
COUNTRY BEARD WHY DO YOU KEEP
USING THIS?
>> BECAUSE IT COMES FROM CHINA.
>> YOU DO HAVE PEOPLE IN THE
ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY WHOSE
LIVES ARE AT RISKS AND FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO CALL IT A CHINESE
VIRUS, FOREIGN VIRUS, THAT IS
JUST NOT -- IT’S SO DANGEROUS
AND NOT A GOOD THING TO DO.
>> THIS IS A VIRUS THAT CAME
FROM THE TERRITORY OF CHINA, BUT
CAME FROM BATS.
THIS IS A BAT VIRUS, NOT A CHINA
VIRUS.
IT DOESN’T SPEAK CHINESE.
>> Sean: TODAY, THE PRESIDENT
HAD A CLEAR MESSAGE FOR THOSE
WHO SEEM MORE WORRIED ABOUT
IDENTITY POLITICS THAN ACTUAL
TRUTH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHY DO YOU KEEP USING THIS?
>> BECAUSE IT COMES FROM CHINA.
>> IT SOUNDS RACIST.
>> IT IS NOT RACIST, NOT AT ALL.
IT COMES FROM CHINA, THAT’S WHY.
IT COMES FROM CHINA.
IT’S ACCURATE.
PLEASE, JOHN.
I HAVE GREAT LOVE FOR ALL OF THE
PEOPLE FROM OUR COUNTRY, BUT AS
YOU KNOW, CHINA TRIED TO SAY AT
ONE POINT, MAYBE THEY’VE STOPPED
NOW, IT WAS CAUSED BY AMERICAN
SOLDIERS.
THAT CAN’T HAPPEN, IT’S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN, NOT AS LONG AS
I’M PRESIDENT.
IT COMES FROM CHINA.
>> Sean: TIMES OF UNCERTAINTY,
FACTS DO MATTER.
THIS VIRUS DID START IN CHINA,
THE WUHAN PROVINCE, AND IT’S NOT
THE FIRST DISEASE TO BE NAMED
AFTER A LOCATION.
FOR EXAMPLE, EBOLA.
THAT’S NAMED AFTER A RIVER IN
AFRICA.
AND THERE’S THE SPANISH FLU, AND
THEN THE MIDDLE EASTERN
RESPIRATORY SYSTEM KNOWN AS --
AND WE CAN GO ON AND ON.
AT THE FACTS ARE CLEAR.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT TRIED TO
COVER IT UP.
THEY KICKED OUT ALSO CALLED
AMERICANS -- I DON’T REALLY
TRUST FAKE NEWS.
THE WALL STREET POST,
"WALL STREET JOURNAL," I DO WANT
THEM THERE.